[Music]
foreign
unbelievable let's bring in kaylee
mackin and co-host of outnumber and
she's also
the former white house press secretary
kaley uh heartbreaking
video there as a mother what is your
reaction lawrence uh it's an absolute
tragedy look when i'm with my daughter
and i walk out the door my husband walks
out the door
she cries when we leave our house i
cannot imagine
in any universe putting my one and a
half year old daughter
with a smuggler crossing the border we
know about a third of these children are
victims of abuse sometimes sexual
sometimes physical
this is a tragedy but we've got to put
responsibility where it should lie
with two people joe biden jensaki
who stood at a podium who told to the
world
you can send your child if you do we
will take care of them over and over
again
over and over they are directly
responsible for the video you just
watched because of their irresponsible
rhetoric which may sound compassionate
but has horrific ends like what we're
seeing in that video just in case our
viewers are waking up and they don't
they don't they haven't seen this video
yet this morning a man and a woman are
caught on a cell phone video
they're walking away from this little
boy they leave him at the border of
ciudad juarez and el paso in texas
and they leave him underneath that
underpass thankfully there was a border
agent close by
who heard the child screaming and went
over there and took the child
the child was carrying his teddy bear
clutching his teddy bear and screaming
where are you going no no no
don't leave we just uh learned
information this morning
that kamala harris is going to guatemala
on sunday and then she's going to mexico
on monday what's your reaction well i i
hope the presidents of those two
countries are
as candid with her as they have been in
interviews where you had the mexican
president
calling joe biden the migrant president
laying the foot of blame
laying the blame at his feet for what
we're seeing at our border you had the
guatemalan president who said
hey you've had some pretty confusing
communications and you've
basically told smugglers if you take a
child we'll let you in so i hope they're
as candid with her
during her photo op tour as they should
be and make no mistake
this is a photo op tour for kamala
harris she wants to be the next
president of the united states
she doesn't want to talk about the
border but she does want to be seen
traveling the world standing next to
foreign leaders
and enhancing her foreign policy chops
it's really pathetic but
also they evidently the behind the
scenes story on of all places cnn.com
is that colin harris's aides are getting
panicked that she's getting labeled
with all the problems at the border
since joe biden gave her the job she's
ignoring
she got another job yesterday by the way
she'll probably not do and that is to
help vote voter reform she's great at
getting a job laughing and then not
doing anything
uh keep that up it really is effective
for the country now let's talk about uh
hunter biden
so it's bad enough that he clearly has
an addiction problem it's bad enough
that he's got these multi-million dollar
jobs
and this uh international fund that
transcends kazakhstan
ukraine over to china but now we have
more emails coming to light more will be
detailed
in a book coming out in september that
shows not only did joe biden lie when he
told us
that he had nothing to do and knew
nothing of hunter biden's international
business dealings he was taking pictures
with his business partners here's what
the new york post editorial says
hunter biden's laptop keeps damning joe
but most media just
ignore it in reality kaylee how long can
this last
well it's going to last and my question
would be where are the investigative
journalists
this should have been out during the
election i remember going up to a group
of reporters
i looked them in the eye and i said to
them why aren't you covering the hunter
biden story
i said will you just do me a favor just
watch tucker carlson
watch the tony bobilinski interview that
was the associate of hunter biden
they did and i said what'd you think of
it they looked at me stared blankly and
said
it was interesting that's what our
reporters are doing
instead of finding this picture instead
of doing what the new york post did
which has put out a story
of the facts they hid the story and
guess what it influenced the election
because you had
13 percent of joe biden voters who said
they would have changed their vote
had they known that would have been
president trump 289
you're forgetting your account was
frozen when you went to retweet the
story exactly along with the new york
post and now jack dorsey apologizes
too little too late you influenced an
election kaylee thanks so much
thank you